i can't believe like the way i was
acting is half the time like when i
think back on it
robert pattinson revealed he nearly got
replaced as edward cullen in twilight
and then at lunch
they were like okay so whatever you're
doing right now you need after lunch
just do the opposite or you'll be fired
by the end of the day and just like that
this et moment at the premiere doesn't
seem as funny what are you hearing about
a sequel if it happens yeah i think
unless i get fired
no kidding rpatz while breaking down his
most iconic characters for gq the batman
star explained his close call behind the
scenes
you know i was 21 and
kind of wanted to make it as arty as
possible and so i was kind of we had
this strange tension where the studio
was kind of a little bit scared to make
things a little bit too
emo
say it
vampire
unlike his beloved vampire character
pattinson admitted his younger self
still had some growing up to do it just
seems so ridiculous talking about it now
because i was literally
in i i spent so much time just
infuriated like the whole i it's
definitely something about being 21 as
well because i was i can't believe like
the way i was acting is half the time
like when i think back on it pattinson
even recalled what scene they were
filming on the day of his near firing at
the scene
when edward introduces bella to his
family the first time i remember that
being the day of my agent my managers
like came up as a surprise visit and i
was like oh hey i just thought
everything was fine and then at lunch
they were like okay so whatever you're
doing right now you need after lunch
just do the opposite or you'll be fired
by the end of the day and i
was like
okay as fans of the book series
phenomenon are well aware pattinson
remained bella swan's one true love for
all five twilight films
i don't know i mean
it's you never ever
you never ever get used to it ever
e.t recently caught up with pattinson's
co-stars kristen stewart and taylor
lautner i was in that
different now
both actors marveled at the franchise's
enduring popularity it's weird because
it doesn't feel
it feels incredibly far away and also
still not that far away from me and my
time in this moment i don't know like um
it on one hand you're like oh i'm old my
god it's like that was five minutes ago
now it's like 10 year anniversary and i
was like wow i have to go to my high
school anniversary already have you ever
had a secret
you couldn't tell anyone
there is this mass resurgence of
twilight and my kids even getting into
it on netflix have you experienced this
have you noticed this are you aware of
it at all
yeah i have um
because
it cut for a while there for the past
few years before that happened it kind
of it was just like the twine moms
stopping me in the street
because yeah it kind of just like
outgrew itself and it was in and i love
the twi moms um but only recently has it
like resurged and we have like these
like young teenagers you know starting
to to watch it and
it is it's crazy to see it come back
around
[Music]